I think our purposes here I did a
crucial in our approach good a good hair
way into into into this discussion is
probably essentially anthropological who
is the person who is the human being the
human person I think I think if we're
very very sincere and a very deep
appreciation of food a human person s
probably with that initial even referee
referring to God but how do we
understand a human person if we are
about to talk about the ethics of how
well he must behave or must not he or
she must behave or must not behave I
think it'd be a very disapoint of
departure is you know but what's our
understanding of the human being who is
man or whose woman who is a human person
that regard and probably trying to
formulate that we can't gradually then
get into the thing about a type of which
happened to it which gets interpreted or
presented as evil not good or less good
and all of that and then also the type
of which our affair which happened to
the human person that gets referred to
as good or you know excellent so I think
that's where I would start I was told I
try to understand you know who we are
and I suppose if we'll put a question to
the audience you may probably get
million ounces about a human person but
I think that's a point of depart
mmediately referring to God I mean
probably from my point of view people
probably Oxford would expect you answer
that probably have started by in our
create sense of the human persons
weren't created by God but I lived up
for later but initiative is what is man
latest right on the star who man is and
then try to then get into the very many
manifestations of man and what therefore
is good what is evil what's not and all
of that you have the the cardinal here
speaking from a humanist perspective
and showing the question of a divine
initial starting point over here I'm not
a religious person I should start by
saying that but I like what the Cardinal
said because he answered your question
with another question and and I think
what is dangerous in this world is that
too often we think we own the truth that
was the peer that was what happened
during the totalitarians 20th century
and we have moved from that to a
situation where we don't think there is
any truth that's why in a way fake news
replace propaganda in propaganda you
believe you're going to impose your
truth fake news you you create the
impression that truth is not worth
pursuing and my only religion is a
non-religious person is to think that
the pursuit of truth is what should
define us
but the idea the illusion that at some
point we find it that's when we begin to
go wrong that's the danger well science
is trying to some sense make good models
of the world which hopefully converge
towards better and better and more and
more accurate descriptions is that the
truth well that is of course something
that keeps the philosophers of science
very busy so this conversation got me
thinking a bit about the link also
between spirituality and human dignity
so one of my favorite thinkers is Pico
della Mirandola who during the
Renaissance wrote oration to the dignity
of man the portal document for humanism
and it's a very interesting document in
the Lord it's a defense that Christians
could totally do alchemy and Kabbalah
the nanotechnology and AI of its era but
the cool part is that section where he
lets go to talk to Adam and say I gave
particular properties to all the other
animals fishes can swim in water lions
are brave but you O Adam has been
wonderful property of not having any
particular property you can become
whatever you want you
can become like a beast or like an angel
and that is of course the foundation for
a humanistic idea of a dignity we are
self creating beings we are in some
sense autonomous and responsible for
ourselves and I think what we're seeing
in modern sciences will is interesting
realization that yeah we are to some
degree able to change our programming
you can speak a single sentence to a
person and change their life that
doesn't happen to a cat you can't
convince a cat by another sentence
however put solemnly pronounce it there
are still limits and the Anthropology of
what kind of creatures we are I think
that is where science can tell us a lot
of valuable things but when we need to
filter it through our more richer in a
philosophical maybe spiritual
understanding of what kind of beings we
are
you